bush et donner la parole à monsieur
jancovici ou à monsieur et/ou à monsieur
mallet pour évoquer un sujet important
et qui est souvent mis en avant sur ce
projet de loi la question du financement
et la question du modèle économique de
ceux de ce projet de loi nous vous
écoutons ce tarif merci beaucoup
alors nous on est ici presque par
accident
on est très content d'être ici mais on
est ici presque par accident parce que
dechy project a vocation à s'adresser
avant tout au monde économique
à la différence de mes collègues qui
sont ici on n'a pas vocation à
s'adresser en premier au monde politique
et on n'a pas vocation à s'adresser non
plus en premier aux français la raison
pour laquelle le nom et anglais c'est
que on a vocation aussi à parler
beaucoup au niveau européen
tout à l'heure il a été évoqué la partie
des cendres vers le bas c'est à dire ce
qui se passe à l'échelon régional
il faut aussi un tout petit peu
s'intéresser à monter vers le haut c'est
à dire ce qui se passe à l'échelon
européen la france n'est pas seule au
monde
il ya quand même un certain de texte
européen qui encadre ce que nous pouvons
faire est par ailleurs sur deux sujets
dont je vais vous parler maintenant
qu'ils sont l'approvisionnement
pétrolier et gazier
si les français pouvaient décider seul
de la quantité de pétrole et de gaz qui
ne veulent consommer
ça serait beau malheureusement ce n'est
pas comme ça que la situation se
présente donc nous sommes
nous avons un tropisme économie
extrêmement fort aux schistes project et
notre écosystème premier on va dire
c'est le monde économique qui a envie de
réconcilier la préservation de notre
maison commune avec une fiche de paye
vous savez que nos concitoyens en ce
moment sauf si un tout petit peu d'avoir
une fiche de paye
ça fait partie de leurs préoccupations
qu'on peut difficilement leur enlever et
dans tous les sondages il vous explique
que l'environnement ils aiment beaucoup
ça sauf qu'une fois qu'ils votent avec
leurs pieds ils vont aller faire autre
chose et c'est normal encore une fois le
monde économique a une importance
centrale qu'on souhaite tous qu'on ne
souhaite pas être malheureusement un
débat un peu derrière nous dans le dans
les démocraties donc ce qu'on cherche à
faire aussi project c'est cette idée un
peu folle d'essayer de réconcilier des
objectifs environnementaux et les
objectifs environnementaux tels qu'on
les voit ils ont souvent un substrat
scientifique fort et des objectifs
économiques parce que si on n'est pas
capable de dire à qui on donne une fiche
de paye et pour quoi faire
dans un monde qui préserve
l'environnement et bien on reste et je
vais être un peu taquin dans la presse
des beaux quartiers parisiens mais on
n'a pas beaucoup avancé
une fois que j'ai dit ça je vais vous
donner quelques éclairages un peu
généraux sur l'énergie et la transition
énergétique art d'abord je voudrais
rappeler une chose toute bête
je suis désolé on n'échappe à son passé
c'est que l'énergie avant d'être un
sujet de débat c'est une grandeur
physique
l'énergie est une grandeur physique qui
mesure les flux donc des vous avez un
flux quelque part de chaleur de
mouvement de réaction chimique etc
vous avez de l'énergie donc vous n'avez
pas de vie sans énergie vous n'avez pas
d'économie sans énergie vous n'avez pas
de modification sans énergie et
inversement plus vous avez d'énergie
plus il se passe un grand nombre de
choses autour de vous donc la
consommation d'énergie d'un individu
n'est rien d'autre que son attitude à
modifier l'espace qui l'environnent un
plus il a d'énergie puis peut déplacer
des objets plus peut chauffer et
refroidir des objets puis se transforme
et c'est ce qui veut dire soit dit en
passant que beaucoup d'énergie propre
c'est impossible par définition propre
c'est toucher à rien à voir beaucoup
d'énergie s'est transformé au cou donc
beaucoup d'énergie propre ça n'existe
pas et très souvent les énergies propres
sont les énergies infinitésimale dès
qu'elles cessent de l'être elle faisait
preuve une fois que les derniers points
l'énergie comme je disais c'est les flux
et donc c'est notamment ce qui permet
aux machines de fonctionner donc si vous
avez une usine et des machines et des
ouvriers et pas d'énergie vous êtes
production si vous avez une voiture
vendue avec un conducteur ait pas de
pétrole
vous n'avez pas de déplacement etc etc
donc l'énergie est un des éléments
absolument indispensable à ce que
fonctionne le monde industriel dans
lequel nous vivons et ce monde
industriel dans lequel nous vivons le
parc de machines qui nous environne en
france représente 500 fois la puissance
musculaire de la population 500 poids en
ordre de grandeur si j'additionne la
puissance en permanence à l'oeuvre des
frigos des pompes qui amène l'eau ici
des voitures de l'éclairage des usines
qui sont en train de faire vos vêtements
et vos chaises etc
tout ça mis bout à bout c'est à peu près
500 fois la puissance musculaire de la
population ce qui veut dire que la
production économique est en premier en
première approximation fonction du
nombre de machines la quantité d'énergie
qu'elles mangent et pas du tout fonction
la taille de la population
c'est la raison pour laquelle la
production économique de la france a pu
pendant un siècle dépassé celle de la
chine alors qu'on est beaucoup moins
nombreux mais pendant un moment on a eu
beaucoup plus de machines que beaucoup
plus grosse et donc ça faisait beaucoup
plus de pib le jour où le nombre de
machines par personne en chine devient
le nombre de machines par personne en
france et bien le pib chinois sera 20
fois le pib français
et je vois pas comment on pourra y
échapper donc le donc le voilà donc
l'énergie c'est ce qui permet à la
civilisation industrielle de gérer ces
flux et donc de gérer derrière la
contrepartie économique de ces flux donc
une loi de transition sur l'énergie
c'est une loi de transition sur la
société c'est pas juste un machin ou il
s'agit de donner trois éoliennes à 3
élus quand nos envies ou deux réacteurs
de -2 écolo qu'on a envie c'est pas ça
le sujet le sujet c'est que la loi de
transition
c'est une loi sur l'organisation
physique de la société c'est une loi sur
le pouvoir d'achat
c'est une loi sur la part des diverses
activités économiques c'est une loi sur
la géopolitique
c'est une loi sur l'europe c'est une loi
sur l'espérance de vie c'est une loi sur
l'éducation et la qualité des soins en
phase i d'une loi sur tout ça d'accord
par construction parce que l'énergie
c'est la physique
alors il faut que je vous ai dit ça
quelques propos un peu plus généraux sur
l'approvisionnement français
on vous a distribué un petit document
j'espère que vous l'avez dans lequel on
vous a donné la répartition par secteur
de consommation et parc-nature d'énergie
primaire donc c'est l'énergie comprend
dans l'environnement et l'énergie
primaire de ce qui se passe en france
donc c'est découpé en résidentiel les
bâtiments dans lesquels vous habitez
tertiaire les bâtiments dans lesquels
vous travaillez industrie c'est les
processus industriels donc ce qui permet
de faire de l'acier de transformer
derrière etc
les machines qui sont dans les chances
c'est l'agriculture enfin les machines
qui servent à déplacer des marchandises
ou à déplacer des gens et on a mis pour
chacune de ces barquettes en milliards
de kilowattheures d'où venaient
l'énergie primaire qui permettait
d'alimenter les machines en question est
ce que vous constatez très facilement
sur ce graphique c'est que l'essentiel
de l'énergie qui permet à la france de
fonctionner comme elles fonctionnent
aujourd'hui vient des hydrocarbures
pétrole et gaz de très loin devant
l'électricité de très loin devant
l'électricité si je regarde d'où vient
la matière qui permet à l'énergie d'être
disponible en france eh bien vous voyez
que sur la partie énergie finale ou et
45% c'est du pétrole qui n'est pas
produit en france 25% c'est du gaz qui
n'est pas produit en france vient
derrière le nucléaire l'uranium n'est
pas non plus produit en france
mais alors que nos importations de
pétrole et de gaz nous coûte
actuellement alors le pétrole vient de
baisser donc l'année dernière nous a
coûté 70 milliards d'euros le radiant
nous
1 donc certes on apporte mais enfin les
ordres de grandeur sont pas exactement
les mêmes même le charbon beaucoup plus
cher que l'uranium est bien évidemment
c'est les combustibles fossiles qui soit
à l'origine de la totalité de nos
émissions de co2 l'électricité non
fossiles quelle qu'elle soit ni concours
que peut elle y concourt au moment de la
fabrication des mois une production bien
évidemment et éventuellement des sites
amont et aval les deux graphiques que
vous avez à la suite vous montrent que
le pétrole et le gaz sont déjà en décrue
subi en europe donc aujourd'hui l'europe
perd à peu près 2% de son pétrole par an
parce que la mer du nord est en déclin
et parce que la production mondiale
nonobstant les gaz de schiste des
pétroles de schiste à peu près flat
depuis 2005
je dis bien à peu près flat depuis 2005
est donc là par un portable par l'europe
est en baisse puisque la consommation
domestique des pays producteurs et la
consommation des pays émergents est en
hausse donc là par un portable de
l'europe est en baisse donc que
l'automobiliste français on ait envie ou
pas pour le moment la quantité de
carburant qui rentre en europe baisse de
2% par an en gros et je ne vous ai pas
mis un autre graphique qui pourtant est
très intéressant si vous regardez
comment évolue la quantité de pétrole
consommé dans le monde et le prix du
pétrole sur un siècle il n'y a pas de
lien entre la quantité disponible et le
prix ça peut vous paraître étonnant il
n'y a pas de lien entre la quantité
disponible et le prix donc quand les
gens vous disent le prix du pétrole
baissent c'est donc on va en avoir plein
c'est faux de même que quand ils vous
disaient le prix du pétrole monte donc
on va en manquer c'est faux les deux
sont faux d'accord il suffit de regarder
les séries longues pour le savoir et ce
qui est en train et là où je suis
d'accord avec géraud guibert c'est que
ce qui est en train de s'annoncer la
maintenance et le prochain choc et la
prochaine récession
c'est juste ça qui est en train de
s'annoncer en ce moment vous avez
également et je mange je fais là juste
une incidence mais j'y reviendrai en
conclusion puisque on parlera de
financement la loi de transition
malheureusement je pense doit s'inscrire
dans un paysage économique qui sera
désormais sans croissance voire en
récession structurelles donc toutes les
mesures dans la loi qui suppose que l'on
va avoir plus d'argent public en gardant
tous les usages publics qu'on a déjà par
ailleurs pour financer quelque chose en
plus ce sont des débats qui sont loin
d'être évident alors ça peut
éventuellement aller de pair avec un
endettement croissant s'il est affecté à
quelque chose
estimé absolument indispensable enfin un
jour ou l'autre l'endettement croissant
dans une économie sans croissance ça se
termine par de l'hyperinflation ou par
du défaut et si c'est pas de
l'hyperinflation ce sera du défaut donc
en ce qui concerne le gaz le gaz est
également en déclin en europe depuis
2005 et j'attire votre attention sur le
fait que pour le gaz comme pour le
pétrole le déclin a démarré avant lehman
brothers
donc l'idée que l'on consomme moins de
pétrole parce que c'est la crise est une
idée à laquelle je ne souscris pas je
pense que d'abord nous avons eu moins de
pétrole et qu'ensuite on a eu la crise
et que c'est bien dans ce sens là que
les choses se sont écrites du reste
depuis que le pétrole s'est fortement
ralentie en termes de production
mondiale c'est-à-dire les chocs
pétroliers 74 79
vous le savez bien puisque vous allez
examiner le budget tous les ans c'est de
cette époque là que débute le problème
de l'endettement de l'état et de
l'augmentation difficile à endiguer du
chômage dans ce pays
donc ce n'est pas d'abord j'ai une
croissance venue de mars et ensuite je
consomme de l'énergie c'est d'abord j'ai
de l'énergie est ensuite j'ai de la
croissance et si j'ai moins d'énergie
moins j'aurai une récession ou quelque
chose qui y ressemble
les flux industriels dans tous les pays
de l' ocde sauf les états unis sont à la
baisse depuis 2007 c'est à dire depuis
le moment où l'approvisionnement
énergétique des pays ocde a tendance à
baisser
je vous ai également rappelé que si je
regarde combien on a dépensé en france
pour importer du pétrole et du gaz sur
les 20 dernières années
on est à peu près dans les eaux de
l'augmentation de la dette souveraine de
la dette de l'état français depuis cette
époque là donc on n'est pas en train de
parler de petites sommes
une fois que je dis tout ça la
conclusion majeure évidemment à laquelle
je vous a même c'est que la loi de
transition doit avoir ce qui n'est pas
le cas aujourd'hui pour objectif premier
de débarrasser l'économie française du
pétrole et du gaz or pour le moment
c'est essentiellement une loi sur
l'électricité c'est à dire ce qui de
notre point de vue ne pose pas de
problème majeur pour le moment pourquoi
est-ce qu'on en est arrivé là je vais
pas vous apprendre votre métier vous
savez très bien que les grands objectifs
de campagne ne correspondent pas
nécessairement l'application de la règle
de trois ça a suivi le fil de l'eau
dans cette affaire qu'est ce qu'on
propose donc on propose de décarbonés
l'économie alors décarbonés l'économie
va se faire pour une très large part par
des économies et pour une part non
négligeable par du changement de mix
mais nous du chiffre on n'est pas du
tout pour que l'on baisse le nucléaire
on pense que c'est pas la priorité loin
s'en faut
dans le contexte actuel je laisserais
après une intervention bri revenir sur
ce qu'on propose de plus précis sur leur
rénovation thermique du logement
je vais vous donner la philosophie
générale de ce qu'on propose la première
chose dans notre philosophie générale
c'est que nous sommes désormais dans une
course contre la montre
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui si on reste
les bras croisés on n'est pas dans un
contexte dans lequel on préserve le
pouvoir d'achat et le pib français
on est dans un contexte dans lequel on
assiste à sa lente érosion à cause de ce
que j'ai dit sur la décrue du pétrole et
du gaz donc en gros le temps joue contre
nous et par ailleurs tout argent dépensé
là où ça n'est pas utile par effet
d'éviction supprime la possibilité de le
dépenser là où il est utile dans un
monde en croissance on peut faire à la
fois des trucs intelligents et des
bêtises dans un monde sans croissance
plus on fait de bêtises et moi on fait
des trucs intelligents
malheureusement on a encore de
l'arithmétique bête et méchante donc ce
qu'on propose sur le bâtiment c'est
d'obliger on propose d'obliger les gens
à rénover alors on le propose de la
manière suivante cd que vous touchez un
bâtiment vous êtes obligé d'embarquer la
performance thermique dans ce que vous
faites donc on va pas vous dire rénover
le sénat demain matin par contre le jour
où vous toucher au sénat vous êtes
obligé d'embarquer la performance
thermique dans ce que vous allez faire
c'est ça l'idée il ya une voiture balai
à bas tout le monde devrait y passer il
ya une voiture balai qui passe derrière
qui est que il ya un niveau minimum de
performance à respecter pour les
bâtiments au fur et à mesure que le
temps passe c'est à dire que alors on
n'est pas tellement le dpe parce que
l'énergie finale a plus de sens pour les
particuliers mais peu importe c'est ça
revient à dire que en 2022 il ya plus
aucun bâtiment classe g qui circulent et
puis en 2025 n'a plus aucun classeurs et
puis et c'est ça l'idée est donc de
voiture balai et on propose de
concentrer les aides uniquement sur ceux
qui ne peuvent pas faire face
économiquement à cette obligation donc
le cadre supérieur il a pas besoin de
crédit là
o il se passe très bien de crédits
d'impôts ça sert strictement à rien ça
d'argent que de l'effet d'aubaine les
les donc il faut obliger tout le monde
est concentré les aides sur ceux qui ne
peuvent pas soit dit en passant
dès qu'on mélange plusieurs objectifs
dans une même politique en général on a
de bonnes chances d'atteindre aucun
et ça je le dis pour la question
difficile certes mais de la précarité
énergétique où on a tendance à mélanger
de trucs et à penser que la précarité
énergétique se traite par le prix de
l'énergie c'est la dernière des bêtises
à faire
il faut le traiter par n'importe quoi
sauf le prix de l'énergie pour moi qu'il
dit ça ça date d'il ya 25 ou 30 ans sur
le tertiaire public
on a poussé très fort un projet qui se
retrouvaient soit dit en passant en très
bonne place dans les propositions faites
par la france à la commission européenne
dans le cadre du plan jeunes coeur donc
sft eux qui a été fait en initié avec la
fnh et qui en gros vise à profiter je
veux pas rentrer dans les détails
aujourd'hui mais vise à profiter d'un
mécanisme qui a été mis en place pour
entre guillemets le sauvetage des
banques à la suite de la crise de lehman
brothers la sfef
ça vise à reproduire le même genre de
mécanisme pour faire intervenir de la
garantie publique non consolidées dans
maastricht pour avoir la possibilité
d'avoir des financements à des taux très
bas pour la rénovation du tertiaire
public qui a l'énorme avantage d'offrir
de très grosses surfaces d'un seul
tenant et donc de perfer de permettre de
mettre en branle les gros acteurs du
bâtiment qui sont par construction ceux
qui peuvent se lancer en premier sur un
marché un peu neuf donc l'idée c'est
qu'il ya que dans le tertiaire public
que vous avez l'ap-hp offre des dizaines
de milliers de mètres carrés d'un seul
tenant
ça peut faire des très gros marché dans
le cadre de ppp où les gros peuvent
prendre le risque de la performance
alors qu'avant que l'artisan du coin de
la rue prennent le risque de la
performance dans la rénovation du
logement il va encore se passer un
certain temps
le deuxième chose que on pousse donc je
laisserais aubry se redire sur la partie
logement sedo décarbonés les transports
décarbonés les transports se fait de
deux manières
enfin de trois manières
alors je vais faire beaucoup de peine à
louis [ __ ] je pense que l'électricité
c'est la troisième et la dernière voir
la 4e et la dernière les deux sont les
trois choses qu'il faut faire avant
c'est juste pour vous donner une idée
les déplacements en voiture c'est un tir
de missile travail un tir mobilité du
quotidien hors domicile travail un tir
longue distance en gros là dedans le
plus essentiel à la stabilité sociale du
pays ces deux déplacements domicile
travail
si les gens peuvent pas aller au travail
on a quand même un petit souci pour ça
il faut massifier en faisant des réseaux
de bus express autour des grandes villes
c'est ce qui en termes de capital
investi et le plus efficace est de très
loin et c'est ce qui permet d'utiliser
la route la route pardon qui est une
infrastructure déjà là si vous regardez
la consommation en capital qui est
nécessaire pour passer la voiture sur le
rer
nous serons tous morts dans cette salle
qu'on n'y sera pas encore donc il faut
passer sur le bus
il faut descendre très très vite la
consommation des voitures en circulation
et ça ça veut dire qu'il faut forcer par
la réglementation un maximum de
consommation des véhicules neufs vendus
et simultanément pro mettre en place la
vignettes
donc en gros si les gens qui ont de
l'argent a toujours envie de rouler dans
une voiture qui consomme beaucoup grand
bien leur fasse
mais il faut qu'ils aient une taxe
annuelle à la détention qui monte très
vite et simultanément il faut offrir aux
gens qui n'ont pas beaucoup d'argent des
voitures à 2 litres au cent et ça
n'arrivera pas tout seul par les
mécanismes du marché
donc là on va aussi avoir un tout petit
sujet qui est la remontée vers le haut à
bruxelles qui est que la concurrence
libre et non faussée pour gérer des
problèmes à 50 ans ça ne marche pas ne
marche pas et enfin là sur la partie
pardon il faut également préserver le
transport interurbain qui va souffrir
puisqu'il est aujourd'hui fait
essentiellement de voitures et d'avions
aujourd'hui il faut le basculer sur du
train parce que les échanges c'est la
paix confrère jean monnet et donc il
faut garder un flux des changes entre
grandes métropoles européennes et le
basculer sur le train l'externalité paix
soit dit en passant mais pas la guerre
n'est jamais prise en compte dans les
bilans sociaux économiques des
transports
jamais c'est très amusant
tu jamais
enfin il faut décarbonés l'industrie
alors décarbonés l'industrie ça veut
dire que de toute façon les flux de
production vont baisser parce que je
disais tout à l'heure l'énergie va
diminuer donc il faut faire plus de
recyclables plus de maintenance donc la
partie une partie de l'industrie va
basculer sur les services c'est normal
c'est je maintient en vie des objets
plus longtemps du coup je les fabrique -
et enfin un concept que on commence à
pousser au shift c'est celui très
étonnant pour une bande d'ingénieurs de
los teques c'est à dire que si on veut
pouvoir modulariser et recycler plus
vous êtes high tech c'est à dire plus
vous faites des trucs sophistiqué et
intégrée et plus vous avez de mal à
retrouver dans l'objet les éléments
élémentaires qui peuvent être réutilisés
pour faire autre chose donc le grand
paradoxe de cette affaire c'est qu'une
partie de la solution peut être high
tech mais une partie aussi est justement
los teques voilà on
je vous ai donné encore une fois j'ai
pas discuter les articles pris un par un
par contre je vous donne un paysage un
peu large qui est celui de l'esprit
général de la loi et malheureusement
aujourd'hui je considère que l'esprit
général de la loi ne répond absolument
pas aux urgences du pays
on est en train de s'offrir un débat qui
est un luxe dont nous n'avons pas les
moyens
je laisse jamais vraiment rapidement
parce que le temps passe que reste
encore à écouter terra nova
donc après on a beaucoup de questions
déjà qui se sont manifestés donc
vraiment très très rapidement monsieur
miles et s'il vous plaît merci monsieur
le président je donc vous propose de
donner quelques remarques pour limiter
mon temps de parole sur on a évoqué
plusieurs fois le terme de précarité
énergétique je veux juste rappeler que
le lab lutte contre la précarité
énergétique est une politique sociale
qui mérite toute l'attention de la
puissance publique mais qui n'apporte
pas grand chose sur le débat énergétique
en dentelle en tous les cas ne répond
pas exactement à nos enjeux
consommation de 2 ans de lutte contre le
co2 pourquoi parce que ayant les ménages
qui sont en précarité énergétique sont
très fortes restrictions et donc les
gains qu'ils sont opérés sur les gains
de confort je pense beaucoup d'autres
d'entre vous autour de la autour de la
table savent mais je veux juste rappeler
encore une fois que il ya souvent
confusion entre lutte contre après
éclate et énergétique c'est une
politique sociale
encore une fois qui mérite toute
l'attention mais ça n'est pas une
politique énergétique en tant que tel
pour les besoins de de co2 le deuxième
point c'est sur le carnet numérique
on avait fait une proposition il ya plus
d'un an maintenant qu'ils avaient été
reprises
nous n'étions pas exactement les seuls
mais cette proposition de passeports
efficacité énergétique ou rénovation
thermique pour accompagner sur la durée
les logements avaient été reprises par
le premier ministre de l'époque jean
marc ayrault et ensuite évoqué dans
différentes instances
aujourd'hui dans la loi il ya le terme
de carnets numérique d'entretien suivi
et d'entretien
tout ça par type exactement du même
concept est une bonne chose je juste
attirer votre attention sur le fait que
sur le terrain les acteurs
professionnels de la filière et même les
collectivités sont un petit peu perdues
sur l'ensemble des termes qui sont
utilisés on parle de carte vitale pour
le plan bâtiment durable de passeport
pour ce qui nous concerne et d'autres
d'autres d'autres acteurs de la filière
de carnets numérique ici de carnet
d'entretien par ailleurs pour les
copropriétés dispositif qui existe déjà
et donc un moment il faudra à mon avis
que les acteurs de l'état les acteurs
publics pour une lisibilité de la
politique sur le terrain rassemble un
peu la terminologie et et concentre un
peu la communication vers un dispositif
que tout le monde comprend et qui est un
peu généralisés donc que ce soit un
terme - ou un autre peu importe il faut
que on y viennent deuxième point est
peut-être je terminerai sur ce test est
là haut niveau il y a des objectifs qui
sont fixés dans la loi certains
ambitieux le cadre général ait défini il
n'en reste pas moins vrai qu'une bonne
partie du succès de cette loi en fait
n'est pas dans la loi en tant que cal
aujourd'hui mais dans les décrets
d'application et l'ensemble des
dispositions qui vont sortir après et je
veux juste attirer l'attention sur l'un
d'entre eux c'est ce qui concerne les
niveaux de performance énergétique pour
ce qui est de la réglementation
thermique de l'existant qui n'est pas
évoquée dans le texte mais mais qui est
en fait déterminant pour le gain
performance des logements dans les
années qui viennent puisque vous savez
bien que pour ce qui est l'enjeu n'est
pas dans les bâtiments neufs qui sont
déjà soumis la rt 2012
et ça n'est pas non plus sur les très
grosses rénovations qui sont très peu
nombreuses mais c'est vraiment l'enjeu
réside dans le diffus est
essentiellement la maison individuelle
pour ce qui est du résidentiel c'est là
que ça se joue
et encore une fois ce sont les critères
de performance qui seront dans cette rt
ex part de moi c'est un peu technique
mais c'est c'est ça qui va déterminer en
grande partie la trajectoire pour le
résidentiel privé
merci merci beaucoup